Gibt es außerirdisches leben wie entwickeln sich planeten und woher kommt die erde warum es die sonnenatmosphäre so unglaublich heißt es gibt noch so
unendlich viele ungeklärte fragen zum universum und antworten auf diese fragen könnte es vielleicht noch dieses jahr geben
denn derzeit sind wir beispielsweise mit
spektakulären missionen nicht nur auf den weg zur sonne oder zum mars auch der merkur ist eines der ziele der menschheit
genauso wie sich auch bei der erforschung von asteroiden dieses jahr noch so einiges tun wird wir stellen die
spektakulärste mission vor herzlich willkommen bei klicks um science-fiction schön dass ihr dabei seid hier gibt es täglich neue science videos abonniert den kanal gerne
Ich kann mich nicht entscheiden welches ist die
spektakulärste weltraum mission ihr könnt am ende darüber abstimmen also schaut genau hin und macht das auch am kommenden dienstag dann gibt es unseren
weltraum livestream mit allen fragen und antworten zur
raumfahrt und 1930 geht es für mitglieder und patches los und um 20 uhr für alle und jetzt also vier super spannende weltraummissionen
nasa-raumsonde insight auf dem weg zum mars anfang mai dieses jahres ist die nasa-raumsonde
insight an bord einer atlas rakete zum mars gestartet eigentlich war die rund
650 millionen teure mission schon für 2016 geplant doch das verzögerte sich dann wegen eines undichten
forschungs instrumentes die landung auf dem mars soll im november stattfinden
inside steht dabei für in terrier exploration using seismik investigation ski und die sea and transport auf deutsch
innen exploration mit seismischen untersuchungen geodäsie und wärmetransport
auch das deutsche zentrum für luft- und raumfahrt dlr ist beteiligt und die forschungsteams offen nicht nur mehr über den mars sondern auch zur entstehung
der erde zu erfahren dazu tilman spohn vom dlr
der mars ist als ziel idealer ist gut zu erreichen und ein ideales
vergleichsobjekte zur erde und damit wird ein großer traum der
planetenforscher und forscherin war denn schon lange wollte man ein
geophysikalisches observatorium auf einem erdähnlichen planeten aufbauen konkret soll die mission
herausfinden wie der mars aufgebaut ist hat er einen flüssigen oder festen kern wie groß
ist der planeten kern überhaupt wie ist der mars mit
kernmantel und christa aufgebaut dafür wird in side den wärmefluss des mars untersuchen und erdbeben messen ein
seismometer wird erschütterung untersuchen bis zu 100 beben auf dem mars erwarten die forschungsteams in den nächsten zwei jahren
alle nicht stärker als 6,0 auf der
richterskala die raumsonde soll sich dafür fünf meter tief in den boden des mars grab und dort die temperatur und wärmeleitfähigkeit
messen mit den ergebnissen erhoffen sich die forschungsteams endlich mehr über
die entstehung der gestand planeten in unserem sonnensystem zu erfahren denn da
wissen wir nur sehr wenig der länder ähnelt vom design her übrigens der raumsonde phoenix die
2008 auf dem mars gelandet war anders als curiosity wird inside allerdings stationär an einem ort bleiben
japanische raumsonde hayabusa 2 auf dem asteroiden drew
schon 2014 war die raumsonde hayabusa 2 gestartet ende juni 2018 hat sie dann ihr ziel fast erreicht
den asteroiden hugo die japanische raumfahrtagentur jaxa meldete dass die sondern sich nur 20 kilometer von rio
befindet und von dort aus messungen vornehmen werde zudem soll von dort auch nach einem geeigneten landeplatz
gesucht werden dazu der missionsleiter marco
yoshikawa wir waren alle sehr erleichtert wir sind weit gekommen aber jetzt beginnt der eigentliche teil der mission
hayabusa 2 wird in den nächsten anderthalb jahren den asteroiden vermessen der übrigens 300 millionen kilometer von der erde entfernt liegt
2020 soll die sonne dann zur erde zurückkehren und proben mitbringen die bei einem dichten überflug
eingesaugt werden auch an bord ein deutscher mini roboter namens mass scott der aus einer höhe von 100 metern auf den asteroiden
absinken soll und zwar im freien fall wobei fall ist hier etwas übertrieben das wird wohl auch eine der größten
herausforderungen zum einen die trennung von der mutter sondern und zum zweiten die landung selbst rio hat so gut wie keine gravitation
etwa so viel wie ein kleiner berg auf der erde es ist mehr also wie ein
andockmanöver an die internationale raumstation iss der länder soll dann auf dem hast du ihnen
bleiben überwacht wird das zehn kilogramm schwieriger weg von köln aus mit dieser mission wollen die forschungsteams mehr zu den ursprüngen des
sonnensystems erfahren asteroiden view sind überreste aus der frühzeit unseres sonnensystems
nasa-sonde parker auf den weg zur sonne nach mehreren verzögerungen war es mitte august 2008 10 soweit die nasa hat ihre
700 kilogramm schwere parkas solar sonde in den äußeren teil der atmosphäre der sonne geschickt wir haben darüber berichtet
durch das schwerefeld der venus soll sie auf eine elliptische bahn gezogen werden so würde die sonde auf
700.000 kilometer pro stunde beschleunigt und wäre somit das schnellste
menschengemachte objekt überhaupt sie soll das magnetische feld der sonne untersuchen und vor allem zwei große rätsel lüften
warum ist die äußere sonnen atmosphäre deutlich heißer als die oberfläche
und wie werden hier die sonnenwinde auf einen wert im überschall bereich beschleunigt und verstoßen so scheinbar gegen die naturgesetze
dazu nicola fox eine wissenschaftlerin des nasa sonden projektes der entstehungsort des sonnenwindes die atmosphäre der sonne ihre
corona muss extrem energiegeladen seinen 300 mal so heiß wie die oberfläche der sonne
das widerspricht den naturgesetzen es sollte keine wärmequelle geben die heißer wird wenn man sich von ihr weg bewegt
dort gibt es irgendeine zusätzliche energie irgendeine
schwarze magie der solar- wind- löst sich nicht einfach von der sonne
er nimmt irgendwie auch ihr magnetfeld mit sich egal in welche richtung es zeigt wie stark es ist es erstarrt im sonnenwind
einige rätsel also rund um die sonne die es zu lösen gilt gilt dabei wird nicht erst seit gestern in diesem zusammenhang geforscht den november
2018 soll sich die sonne dann das erste mal der sonne annähern und in den nächsten sieben jahren weitere
25 mal an der sonne vorbei fliegen im dezember 2024
wird sie dann ihren sonnennächsten punkt wohl das erste mal erreichen jedes mal werden die
fluktuierenden magnetfelder und die geladenen partikel gemessen und so hoffentlich alle rätsel zu den sonnen winden aufgeklärt hat so nicola fox am
spannendsten wird unsere erste dichte annäherung sein die wird zwar noch nicht am missionsziel von zehn
solarien sein sondern erst war etwa 35 radien aber
das ist immer noch viel mehr
als alles andere zuvor wir werden und kartierte das gebiet erreichen einen bereich mit der warnung hier sind drachen
genau das ist spannend dort zu sein wo noch niemand anderes war
die forschungsteams versprechen sich neben einem größeren verständnis für die sonne auch sehr konkrete praktische
anwendung sie wollen durch die hoffentlich neu gewonnenen erkenntnisse die sterne generell aber auch die wirkung der sonne auf das klima den
klimawandel und das wetter besser einschätzen können baby colombo mission zum planeten merkur märkte ist mit einem durchmesser von knapp
4200 kilometer nur ein bisschen größer als der erdmond und damit der kleinste planet des sonnensystems
er ist der sonnennächste planet und durch die europäische japanische mission bepicolombo
will man nicht nur erkenntnisse zur entstehung des gesamten sonnensystems bekommen sondern zu den erdähnlichen
terrestrischen planeten überhaupt doch das ganze gestaltet sich gar nicht so einfach denn in der merkur
umlaufbahn ist die sonneneinstrahlung
achtung
zehnmal höher als auf der erde und das müssen instrumente und satelliten auch erst einmal überstehen eine weitere herausforderung stellt die
anreise da denn der merkur ist im gegenteil zum mars oder zu venus nur durch ein langwieriges ab
bremsmanöver erreichbar konkret wird die sonde die gravitationskraft von merkur venus und erde nutzen um durch neun manöver den
absturz ins sonnensystem innere abzubremsen die baby colombo besteht aus zwei satelliten zum einen aus dem japanischen merkel
magnetosphäre kredite mmo und zum zweiten aus dem europäischen mercury planetary orbiter mpo beide werden auf
unterschiedlichen umlaufbahnen unterwegs sein um den merkur zu erforschen die japanische sonde wird sich vor allem sein
magnetfeld vornehmen und auch das wechselwirkung mit dem sonnenwind
untersuchen die europäische sonde soll dagegen auf einer niedrigeren umlaufbahn unterwegs sein und die innere zusammensetzung des planeten erforschen
konkret sollen unter anderem die folgenden fragen beantwortet werden ist der kern des merkurs fest oder flüssig ist der planet
tektonisch aktiv und wie sind die krater an den polen beschaffen die permanent im dunkeln liegen staaten soll die mission im oktober
2018 und zwar mit einer ariane-5-rakete vom weltraumbahnhof kourou die reise zum merkur wird insgesamt sieben jahre dauern
ob sie erste ergebnisse gibt es also ab
2025 unter dem ihr oben da könnt ihr jetzt abstimmen welches
ist die spannendste mission und warum ist die jeweilige mission die spannendste für euch das schreibt bitte in den kommentaren
und wenn ihr keines der ergebnisse der mission
verpassen wollte auch zu allen anderen denen kein video mehr verpassen wollt dann habe ich am ende dieses videos einen kleinen tipp für euch
wenn ihr beim mitglieder livestream am kommenden dienstag dabei sein wollt dann
werdet mitglied
hier unter dem video draufklicken oder auf den link in der video beschreibung und ihr bekommt noch exklusiver extra wieses eben live streams und
noch ein paar weitere privilegien für einen kleinen beitrag
und zudem machen wir mit euren beiträgen klicks um werbefrei und jetzt mein tipp wenn er immer
garantiert über aktuelle videos informieren werden wollt dann hättet mich bei whatsapp
nur da bekommt ihr das aktuelle video deutlich vor allen anderen von mir persönlich auf euer handy einfach
draufklicken und darunter geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken 1000 raketen zum mars bis dann
bleibt dran